THANK YOU.
GREAT SHOW.
BUCKLE UP.
GLAD YOU ARE WITH US.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
THE JUDICIAL WATCH HAVE EQUALLY
ON THEIR OWN ON EARTH SOME OF
THE MOST DAMNING EVIDENCE
EXPOSING A TWO-TIERED JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
HER LAWYER CHERYL MILLS AND
SAMUELSON TO DISPOSE OF EVIDENCE
AND REFUSED TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL LAW.
NOW, TRUST ME, DONALD TRUMP
WOULD NEVER RECEIVE THIS SPECIAL
TREATMENT.
FIRST, WE BEGIN, DEMOCRATS, THE
MEDIA MOB, ONCE AGAIN, THEY HAVE
TEAMED UP TO ACCUSE.
I FORGET WHAT TO TAKE OF THE
WEEK IT IS.
WE'VE GOT ALL THE FACTS AND
EVIDENCE WE'LL LAY OUT ABOUT
WHAT IS HUMAN SUFFERING, A
TRAGEDY.
NOT JUST IN THE CITY OF
BALTIMORE, BUT PRETTY MUCH EVERY
LIBERAL CITY ACROSS THIS COUNTR
COUNTRY.
NOW, FOR MONTHS WE HAVE BEEN
CHRONICALLY ON THE SHOW, WHAT IS
THE BIGGEST DISASTER IN THE MOST
LIBERAL CITIES OF AMERICA.
BY THE WAY, GRIFF JENKINS, LAST
WEEK, HE TOOK A TOUR AT ONE OF
THEIR LARGER FACILITIES OR DO
YOU KNOW, THE ONES THAT LIBERALS
HAVE BEEN COMPARING TO CANCER
STOMACH CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
BABY FORMULA, DIAPERS, SOCCER
FIELDS, OTHER RECREATIONAL.
ALL COURTESY OF YOU THE
TAXPAYER.
NOT IDEAL, BUT THEY DIDN'T
RESPECT OUR LAWS.
BUT THEY ARE DEFINITELY TRYING.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE CITY OF
BALTIMORE, OVER THE WEEKEND, THE
PRESIDENT CALLED OUT 13 TERM
CONGRESSMAN, ELIJAH CUMMINGS,
FOR FAILING TO ADDRESS ONE OF
THE DIRE PROBLEMS RIGHT HERE IN
HIS DISTRICT, WHICH IS
EXPERIENCING RECORD VIOLENCE,
POVERTY, FAR WORSE THAN THE
FACILITY JENKINS WENT TO, AND
CORRUPTION ON A NEARLY
UNIMAGINABLE SCALE.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU ABOUT THIS
IN A MINUTE.
NATURALLY, INSTEAD OF FOCUSING
ON THE DETERIORATING LIVING
CONDITIONS IN BALTIMORE,
DEMOCRATS ARE JUST DEFENDING
CUMMINGS WITH ANOTHER ROUND OF
IDENTITY POLITICS, FAME, ELECTED
MORAL OUTRAGE, AND OF COURSE
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT, CALLING
HIM A RACIST EVERY SECOND, EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
HE SAID IT WAS RAT INFESTED.
LET'S SEE.
JUST LAST YEAR, THE MAYOR OF
BALTIMORE, THEN MERRICK,
CATHERINE LITERALLY SAID SHE
COULD SMELL THE RAT WHEN WALKING
THROUGH A NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN HER OWN CITY, SHE SAID IT.
WATCH.
>> ABOUT A YEAR AGO, CITY
LEADERS IDENTIFIED SOME OF THE
CITY'S MOST VIOLENT
NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> WHAT.
WE SHOULD JUST TAKE ALL THIS
DOWN.
>> UNDER BALTIMORE'S VIOLENCE
REDUCTION INITIATIVE.
IT IS ABOUT TAKING STEPS.
>> YOU CAN SMELL THE DEAD
ANIMALS.
>> Sean: THE MAYOR OF
BALTIMORE SAID THAT.
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING.
NO OUTRAGE FROM DEMOCRATS ON
THOSE COMMENTS.
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS COMPARED
BALTIMORE TO A THIRD WORK, WORLD
COUNTRY.
IT'S ONLY IF YOU ARE WITH TRUMP.
ONLY IF YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE.
ONLY IF YOU WERE APPOINTED BY
TRUMP.
JUST LIKE, OH, OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, HILLARY CAN DO WHATEVER
SHE WANTS.
TRUMP HAS NO OBSTRUCTION, BUT HE
CAN DO DOMINIC WOW.
>> THE FACT IS THAT AMERICA IS
THE WEALTHIEST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD.
BUT ANYONE WHO HAS WALKED AROUND
THIS NEIGHBORHOOD WOULD NOT
THINK YOU WERE IN A WEALTHY
NATION.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT YOU WERE IN
A THIRD WORLD COUNTRY.
A COMMUNITY DOES STOMACH THAT
DOES NOT EVEN HAVE DECENT
QUALITY OF
GROCERY STORES WHERE MOMS CAN
BUY QUALITY FOOD FOR THEIR KIDS.
GETTING A HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
MANY KIDS IS AS REAL AS IT IS TO
THE MOON.
>> Sean: BERNIE SANDERS CALLED
BALTIMORE, WHILE A THIRD WORLD
NATION.
FRANKLY, THEY HAVE GOTTEN
DRAMATICALLY WORSE.
IT IS A CRISIS.
THEIR RODENT INFESTATION HAS
BECOME SO BAD, A RECENT DOCUMENT
DOCUMENTARY.
VACANT BUILDINGS LINED MANY
STREETS IN BALTIMORE.
THERE ARE NEARLY 17,000
ABANDONED STRUCTURES IN CITY
LIMITS.
LET'S LOOK AT THE RECORD.
IT IS IN A STATE OF RUINS.
ZERO STUDENTS IN FIVE BALTIMORE
HIGH SCHOOLS AND ONE MIDDLE
SCHOOL WERE PROFICIENT IN MATH
AND ENGLISH THERE WASN'T ONE
STUDENT PROFESSION.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING.
IT TOTALED, BY THE WAY.
THE NEEDLES ALL OVER THE
STREETS, PEOPLE, IN THE STREETS,
THE IN THE STREETS.
IN HER HOME DISTRICTS, ALL LOOKS
LIKE THE REPRESENTATIVES NEED TO
FOCUS ON THEIR DISINTEGRATING
DISTRICTS, RIGHT BEFORE YOUR
EYES.
OPEN YOUR EYES.
BALTIMORE'S UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS
THE THIRD HIGHEST OF ANY MAJOR
CITY IN AMERICA.
THE POVERTY RATE AND BALTIMORE,
A WHOPPING.
HOUSEHOLD MEDIUM INCOME IS
$11,000 LESS THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
LOOK AT THIS.
2017, BALTIMORE NAMED THE MOST
DANGEROUS BIG CITY IN AMERICA.
MORE PEOPLE MURDERED IN
BALTIMORE THAN EVER BEFORE.
THERE WERE MORE THAN TWICE AS
MANY SHOOTINGS IN BALTIMORE THAN
IN CHICAGO.
YEAH, THAT'S CHICAGO.
IN 2018, THE CITY'S MURDER RATE
WAS HIGHER THAN IN ANY, AND IT'S
BEEN HIGHER THAN IN THE COUNTRY
OF HONDURAS.
WHAT?
THEY ARE FLEEING TO SEEK ASYLUM
AT THE U.S. BORDER.
THIS YEAR, BALTIMORE'S MURDER
RATE IS ON THE RISE HAD.
BETWEEN THE FIRST HALF OF 2019,
A 16% INCREASE IN MURDERS.
28% INCREASE IN NONFATAL
SHOOTINGS.
THERE IS A MASS EXODUS GOING ON,
AND I CAN'T BLAME PEOPLE FOR
THIS.
INCLUDING A 20,000 DROP SINCE
2010.
"NEW YORK TIMES," EVEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" CALLING IT
THE TRAGEDY OF BALTIMORE.
NOW, WHO CAN BLAME PEOPLE FOR
LEAVING JUST LIKE THEY ARE
LEAVING IN DROVES AS A MASS
EXODUS OUT OF THESE HIGHLY
REGULATED HIGH TAX STATES LIKE
THIS ONE.
I'M STUCK IN, BECAUSE OF WORK
MAKES ME STAY HERE.
NEW YORK OR NEW JERSEY OR
CALIFORNIA OR ILLINOIS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, WE ARE NOW
WITNESSING A HUMAN CRISIS.
WE'VE GOT TO DO BETTER.
THE PEOPLE IN THOSE DETENTION
CENTERS THAT BROKE THE LAW,
DIDN'T RESPECT OUR BORDERS, OR
SOVEREIGNTY, THEY ARE LIVING
BETTER THAN THE PEOPLE OF
BALTIMORE AND OTHER BIG LIBERAL
CITIES.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
BUT THEY ARE CALLING THOSE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS AND
COMPARING THOSE TO NAZI GERMANY.
THEY HAVE FAILED THEIR CITIZENS
FOR DECADES.
LIBERAL DEMOCRATIC POLICIES HAVE
FILLED THE PEOPLE OF BALTIMORE.
JUST LIKE THE PEOPLE IN
SAN FRANCISCO, JUST LIKE THE
PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES,
NEW YORK CITY.
AND ELSEWHERE
HE'S BEEN IN WASHINGTON FOR 23
YEARS.
I ALL WHILE HIS DISTRICT IS
BECOMING WORSE AND WORSE AND
WORSE.
ONE OF MANY CITIES RUN BY
LIBERALISM, EXPERIENCING THESE
SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
WHICH IS WHY ON THIS PROGRAM, WE
HAVE INVESTIGATED MULTIPLE
CITIES WHICH ARE DETERIORATING
RIGHT BEFORE OUR EYES.
VIOLENT CRIME, DRUG ADDICTION,
PROPERTY, VIOLENCE WREAKING
HAVOC IN METROPOLITAN AREAS, ALL
WHILE DEMOCRATS ARE UNWILLING OR
UNABLE TO ADDRESS THESE VERY
REAL PROBLEMS.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU ARE GOING TO
LEAVE NEW YORK, FINE.
DON'T BRING YOUR IDIOTIC LIBERAL
POLICIES WITH YOU.
IF YOU ARE LEAVING COME OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND TEXAS.
DON'T DO TO TEXAS WHAT YOU DID
TO CALIFORNIA, WHAT YOU ARE NOW
TRYING TO GET AWAY FROM.
SAN FRANCISCO, ONE OF THE MOST
LIBERAL CITIES IN AMERICA,
IMAGINE THIS.
1 MILE FROM NANCY PELOSI'S GATED
COMMUNITY HOME, 1 MILE AND THE
OTHER DIRECTION TO HER OFFICE,
THE HOMELESS PROBLEM SPIRALING
OUT OF CONTROL.
PUBLIC,, AND MUCH WORSE.
L.A.
THEY HAVE FAILED TO ADDRESS
THESE VERY REAL ISSUES, WHICH
HAVE REAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
EVERYBODY LIVING IN THESE
COMMUNITIES.
SO, TONIGHT IS EVERYBODY IN THE
MEDIA MOB, HE TOLD THE TRUTH.
IF YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT PEOPLE,
ALL YOU PEOPLE ON THE LEFT, IF
YOU CARE ABOUT PEOPLE, HOW ABOUT
YOU FIX THESE CITIES?